just in case you confused it with
nowhere in Mexico
typing subtitles these guys argue about
how to kill Hannibal well basically so
that a movie can happen kick Mac will
kill this idiot I know he's dumb but
he's fired a gun before for sure now
let's let the dogs go him because ya
still need him for this movie next time
amigo this is a cute reference to
Hannibal's I love it when a plan comes
together saying meaning he's got a plan
already a plan that called for the
captors to try and shoot him with his
own gun instead of theirs and then
decide to wait and let the dogs kill it
dogs keep running into a looping time
warp that has found itself in this
warehouse somewhere in Mexico and they
left his gun that didn't work right next
to him stupidest captors ever movie
makes the dogs run into the shadows
because whatever Hannibal does to get
out of this without shooting them is
almost certainly bullsh Liam Neeson
isn't killing anyone in this scene not
even a dog and of course they also let
the captive keep his GPS device I mean
it was so obvious the dogs were gonna
take care of him why bother searching
him right nobody gives fewer folks about
its plot details than you do you can
outrun the cops in Mexico in a car like
this but you definitely cannot hide this
assholes name translated in English is
guy who helps the movie ripoff Indiana
Jones I like this whole SantaFe motif
you got going here to go New Mexico is
this a discount Breaking Bad because I
might actually award points if it is
convenient Reese Tolan van is convenient
you checking me what is this opposite
day
opposite day you should have told us
stranger I leave no you fool be a
hopefully defined stranger for us so we
can follow along you just shot me but
what the hell you have the same tattoo
as me so it's all water under the bridge
man know where you are sir
what are the odds that these two Army
Rangers would bump into each other in
the middle of bump Mexico I don't
subscribe to coincidence corporal but
screenwriters do know I need your help
to save another and I'm hoping you can
just gloss over that whole I just shot
you think you I actually believe that
you got bad guy continues monologuing
even after his captive says this so that
Hannibal and BA have time to get here we
already send the convenient timing of ba
and Hannibal meeting in the desert and
the convenience of the bad guy
monologuing instead of killing face but
how the face know that all these other
conveniences we're going to conspire to
keep him alive you could literally close
your eyes and have just as much clues to
what's going on as if you were watching
this
face would be excellent at cinemasins
Thank You Peck Baracus so good these
guys are all meeting for the first time
Hollywood gives us yet another origin
story we didn't ask for need I guess the
bad guys know exactly where the
fledgling a-team went after their daring
escape I'm a real soldier I'm orion's
your baby
well isn't somewhere in Mexico a
geographical oddity has more disgraced
Army Rangers per capita than anywhere in
the world director has a writing credit
so you know this is gonna rule just like
when M night Shyamalan does it October
to 6:00 I see bad aim Academy graduated
their senior class today movie destroys
literally my favorite thing about the TV
show 16 minutes in I'm no helicopter
scientist but I feel confident saying
bullshit seekers life even if you
somehow know the Mexican helicopters
payload you fuckin counted the missiles
he fired at you while your chopper was
upside down face definitely doesn't have
the strength to one-arm ba back at at
the helicopter they should have lost to
Army Rangers right there but I imagine
they would have found two more at a
truck stop later movie rips off the
stalled vehicle that is falling starts
just in time to avoid a crash cliche
from literally everything bigger meat
was set a 20 minute movie oh thank god
damn it any one of those 80 missions
were probably more entertaining than the
one we're about to watch also yeah but
how many failures I refuse to believe
this ragtag group of stubborn soldiers
managed to successfully complete 80
missions without also fucking up just as
many missions also be a said he was
dishonorably discharged did they just
give that guy a clean slate and welcome
him back like the prodigal son because
I'm here to tell you the military does
not do prodigal sons they don't do
welcome backs face one night bombed or
noob okay Murdock burn the hell out of
everyone knows only assholes order steak
well-done yeah
oh good these two characters have some
sort of romantic history any time these
two talk about their relationship
I'm just gonna skip it is that cool the
only mint outside of the u.s. capable of
printing our money belonged to the Shah
of Iran he's just gonna casually drop
that and just move on like it's nothing
there's some rumors Benson
secret plates oh I get it we didn't see
the other eight emissions because they
didn't involve a romantic subplot
crashing into an illegal military
operation clashing with a legal military
operation if you're gonna make a play
for these plates I'm waving you off
right now well isn't it convenient that
the a-team is being simultaneously
recruited and prohibited for the same
mission I mean did Jessica Biel and
Lynch coordinate their polar opposite
requests to be simultaneous he never
came back
sorry skip he's wearing body armor in
the HQ and that should tell you
everything you need to know about CIA
that they read the news and that
sometimes even US soldiers on base go
back crazy and shoot people oh you meant
the easy joke that they're paranoid
sorry I was taking you literally there
for a second remember people you are not
in reality you're not even in movie
reality you are in coincidence land an
alternate dimension where any crazy
convenient plot development not only can
happen but does happen I'm ten times
them now I was when you know um Liam
Neeson isn't killing anyone in this
scene I figured the black forest guys I
get it they're like Blackwater there's
no way they're evil we'll make it a week
but you guys make it a year
rival team is in it for the money not
the science but I started foot inside
her crafter you ever gonna let me live
that down nope so in the last eight
years Murdock has never piloted this
crew again since that initial scene we
saw ba hasn't had to be in an aircraft
all that time is the movie daring me to
hate it let's go fool nobody on a
populated army base notices this door or
this engine getting pulled off the truck
hit the media attempt see what's lying
around tons of media credentials I'm
sure briefed our reference is so
hilarious that the movie inserts a laugh
break where is Hannibal Smith do
captain's generally get away with
talking to generals like this captain
face your point of entry is under though
tell the Foreign Press private security
okay so the whole reason to get a press
pass was to enter this hotel so that
face could get to the sewer great but
why can't I just go to the sewer great
without going through all that later ba
joins the action further down the road
with a stolen motorcycle
he doesn't need a sneak past anybody so
all that nonsense with getting the press
passes was pretty worthless let me put
it this way Jerry Rice dropped some
passes in his career and catching passes
is not a hard job compared to this these
guys can account for everything and
Baghdad on a secret mission and there's
no variables and never a mistake you
want a motorcycle to blow up a truck
without accounting for speed or changing
course or any other human elements you
got it
hey let's
just leave this thing full of money wide
open and sitting unguarded see what
happens when you leave this unattended
highly-trained a team that can do an
impossible mission suddenly can't aim so
bad guys can get away also Liam Neeson
isn't killing anyone in this scene
because its aim is horrible also the
movie steals the ragtag military unit
gets betrayed by higher-ups during a
dangerous op thing from the losers
although you could argue the losers is
kind of an 18 ripoff already but since
we don't care much for source material
discount the losers once in my house
Black Forest been brought to trial
because they're run by chick Dini this
Court is rendering guilty verdicts for
each member of this alpha unit or a team
roll credits also this movie just took
41 minutes to give us the same set up
the TV show gave us in 60 seconds of
introduction narration you're all hereby
stripped of formal rank and dishonorably
discharged mr. Baracus you are
dishonorably discharged again somehow
you just stripped them all rank dude
he's not a colonel anymore and these are
not his men dumbass judge in case you
confused it with prison your fault
Sumter sound the value of the name
unless so wait did they leave visitation
go into this yard and say a couple
things then go straight back to
visitation to finish up this thought
this drug should last long enough to
declare me dead and have me placed into
a crematorium and allow me to wake up a
split second before the burners consume
me in a fiery death also movie whips out
the mysterious drug you can take that
makes you appear dead when you're really
just in a deep sleep from well shit if
we're being honest from Shakespeare but
also from a ton of movies a director on
ER saw mission impossible and/or clear
and present danger slammed his fist on
the table and said we have to have the
exact same actor to play the CIA
director in this movie will be
completely glosses over how the unknown
persons managed to drag the tanning
booth out of the prison into this spot
but hey this is the same movie that
suggests face had a Dave & Buster's in
his cell a few moments ago so I guess
it's par for the course come on how are
they certain he would pay attention to
the fucking license plates also why
don't any of the guards paying attention
if it's so obvious guard waits until ba
is all the way in the back of the boss
before saying anything to it how did you
know that once that door was extracted
that it would take his weight remember
the guy we did
swales but that was a midget characters
described a more interesting plot than
the movie they're currently in ham and
red-eye gravy is a sin at 399 or any
other price I can't kill anybody
damn now ba literally pities the fools
instead of killing them okay I'm done
I'm walking out of here for a bit I
might retire not sure yet I'm gonna have
to go down an undocumented amount of
vodka to believe what I just saw
also ba is driving this Hummer right and
he took a vow of non-violence right so
how could he be sure there was no one he
could run over when he ran through this
wall and for the remainder of the scene
absolutely no one will try and stop
these guys military presence is not
required at military outposts how is
Jessica Biel not caught up with him yet
how do they have time for this bullshit
thankfully for being well there's only
one plane taking off from this airbase
right now so she can easily identify
which plane has the fugitives in it this
military SUV went to the Prometheus
school running away from things whew now
that you're up in the air who could
possibly get in another plane and stop
you damn she'd be good at cinemasins too
and she's hot human being in a falling
tank is better at shooting drones than
drones are at shooting human being also
after this explosion face and the rest
of the a-team are dead this is where the
movie jump the tank there dropped the
tank native jump the tank NATO whatever
this is where the movie got so stupid
that even the early scenes were laughing
at it hold on hold on here people wait
just know you over there you go call
Neil deGrasse Tyson right now I need to
understand the physics of what's being
displayed here because my inner nerd
says this is impossible to achieve let
alone survive it's too bad this phone
numbers fake because I have many
questions and comments and if we kill
this innocent German who gives a fuck he
is German swept up for church sweating
like a whore in church cliche hell no
answer I've seen this person before no
you were basically following that
asshole around six months ago the movie
made a big deal about it like you kind
of knew he was a bad guy with whom am i
speaking
this is kept uh Tennant so sighs this
agent Lynch the movie's gone to great
lengths to show that not only the lots
of CIA agents go by the name agent Lynch
as an alias but also that this
particular agent Lynch is basically a
ghost so how the fuck did she manage to
pick up a phone and call him based on a
satellite picture of his face that
reminded her of his name
militated Smith's escape and are
currently aiding and abetting him hmm
Oh buddy I'm going to have to go out of
my way to disappoint you movie let's
character speak forward in direct
address to audience also Jessica Biel
said this exact same thing to me once
though I thought the request I'd made
was well within the bounds of reason our
surveillance has him in an unknown Arab
making regular trips from the train
station to the bank obviously general
Morrison is confused for an unknown Arab
honestly did the military even check the
remains of that I'm the explosion at all
I mean even if they didn't realize this
is Morrison they should at least be able
to realize it's a white dude in an Arab
costume oh come on you want to go there
skip in Germany apparel you can climb
out of cars with automatic weapons
brandished and no one thinks it's weird
here comes the air
Murdock is on standby in a helicopter
flying around Frankfurt but apparently
the city doesn't give a shit about rogue
helicopters this will be a 62% cartoon
Bulls like this they won't revenge on
pike they even discussed killing him but
no we're just here for the plates right
now we'll revenge this dude later for
some reason this guy is supposedly a top
covert operative but he aims like a
novice I'm a bad guy with everything to
lose but let's drop the gun and
fistfight this dude because machismo
what the fuck is going on you know this
is we all do Kelsey Grammer no Hannibal
just now put this all together
I saw your tumor darling yeah about that
how did you manage to attend the funeral
after being arrested us could you do
that to us well Morris dude this is an
absolute total bullsh question from left
field and good thing too because it
eventually leads to Hannibal figuring
out dr. house style that a drone has
headed their way it looks exactly like
Call of Duty doesn't alright yeah except
Call of Duty will tell you that you got
the kill you actually have to verify
that on your own in the real world get
an agency scrub team out there and get
me the goddamn plates back are you sure
those plates weren't melted in the
explosion I mean that was pretty stupid
to do with the plates where anywhere
inside that house yes we have weapons no
you may not want us is that how that
works
kids don't try this at home even with a
badge that's a tackle on what do we do
boss
I don't know hard luck I love it when a
plan doesn't come together where I think
I like the I lose a friend
oh god well it's kind of specific but
still pretty damn vague the LA docks are
like a small operation or anything you
want to tell me which slit maybe any
bullshit and ran from that said deal's
off did we get him no why did you
fucking hang up you were the one that
ended that call stupid lady don't be mad
at your underlings or even Hannibal it's
all on you babe and you are asking babe
but still a fault here previously on the
18th so face gave her a phone and said
hold on to it and that's the phone she's
got sitting out on the table in front of
her because it gets called all the time
or what here's where the movie that
delights and showing you the preparation
and planning goes against type and hides
a big secret from you solely because the
finale demanded it laughs I think you
threw Benowitz transportation hilarious
passport mix-up from the team that plans
everything down to the letter this movie
does not give any folks whatsoever about
what should happen when I'm gasps wait
Neal what what did Murdock have to call
the matrix and download Swahili into his
brain the fuck took him so long movie
unintentionally inspires entire
Expendables franchise with a few pyrrole
shots of a plane flying awesome any damn
things in a way because overkill is
underrated
no no it's properly rated movies like
this we're overkill like a badge that's
why we can never expect more for movies
even once called the a-team
montage if you don't understand
preparing for the final heist or
standoff cliche and you put them on
display in the home world any questions
yeah about a million at the ship no one
discussed meeting at contact well
there's no way you can see who's down
here amongst the chaos fireworks
exploding cars and others fit but sure
it's Beckham Baracus what is happening
man would all the characters in this
movie be good at cinema since the hell
was that
Mike Anderson do you have any clue where
that rocket came from or who fired it
dude fired one rocket at the hole and
now the ship is just spontaneously
spouting secondary explosions whenever
the script feels like it BA survives an
unpredictable and catastrophic shipping
container avalanche where does this dude
keep getting extra rockets for this
thing he stole that from one of Lynch's
soldiers after killing him did that guy
have a stash of rockets next to him that
bike is now lugging around all over the
place
Oh what the hell let's put another
mystery explosion on that boat two hours
suppose it action comedy movies somehow
makes itself feel longer than Doctor
Zhivago
you know it has some just kill him
already there were ties faster
then why did you get beat up the first
time around unless you have a piece of
paper that looks like no boy I sure I'm
glad this character I didn't care about
got to shove those words back in his
face Murdock you scamp yeah there are
actually four members of the a-team we
just haven't seen this one for the
entire finale because the movie
apparently thinks he's worthless and
kind of surprised if not another
explosion happening on that boat
rightfully now ah they dragged poor Jon
Hamm into this didn't they
and skip instead of just ending movie
decides to rip off the girl law
enforcement officer helps her prisoner
lover escape ending from out of sight
they survive as soldiers of fortune
movie gives you the finger by first
showing you a two-hour protracted origin
story then using the end credits to show
you how much more quickly they could
have accomplished that feat but how do
you protect the face you don't mess with
it kid scare Murdock's nuts Ruby doesn't
respect the original cast enough to give
them cameos in anything other than
pointless post credits scenes Oh
dude observation Athleta laughter we are
laughing on the charge of conduct
unbecoming a United States Marine the
members finally accused guilty as
charged
monkey I want her phones her computers
any support packages she operates I want
to know everything I want him dead
I want his family dead I want us house
burnt to the ground
trench oh this is embarrassing
yeah sure is why'd you say never
happened to me let me show you my plan
for sending you home please excuse the
crudity of this model I didn't have time
to build it to scale at a paint I'll
pick up the rest side see that it had a
certain panache that's what I'm good at
not the work not the work presentation